Trump is doing it.
He is starting to say there is funny business
as he starts to lose Michigan, as he starts
to lose Wisconsin, as Nevada may be beyond
repair for him.
We don't know it's early.
I'm just telling you the numbers as of this
moment.
Donald Trump came out at 2:00 a.m. last night
and he said we won Trump.
Listen, guys, I hate that we were right about
these things.
But I told you Monday Trump would claim premature
victory when there was no victory to claim
he did it at two a.m. last night.
Trump said he was winning Wisconsin, Michigan,
Pennsylvania, Georgia, North Carolina states
that had not yet been called.
We all knew the reality of the Red Mirage
scenario of huge numbers of outstanding absentee
and mail in ballots.
And this morning, slowly but surely, Wisconsin
flipped blue, small margin, Michigan flipped
blue, small margin.
We are anticipating at least a tightening
in Pennsylvania as they resume counting votes,
although we don't know exactly how it will
go.
Nevada still in the blue column.
So now Trump has to do it.
Now he has to question whether this is rigged.
Donald Trump tweeting just a little while
ago, quote, Last night, I was leading often
solidly in many key states, in almost all
instances, Democrat run and controlled.
Then one by one, they started to magically
disappear as surprise ballot dumps were counted.
Very strange.
And the pollsters got it completely and historically
wrong.
He is doing it, the president of the United
States is saying not just, oh, there are some
questionable ballots in Florida and we have
the paper ballots and it's hanging chads and
we just have to look.
No, no, no, no, no.
Trump is actually suggesting that swath tranches,
we could call them cohorts of imaginary mail
in ballots are being fabricated to steal states
from Trump.
The president of the United States is making
that assertion on Twitter.
They are counting ballots.
We knew this would happen.
Many states report in-person numbers very
quickly and then start counting mail in ballots
and then they stop for the night and then
they start again.
I told you that this would happen, we predicted
it and I urged calm, I urged calm last night.
We have to wait for the ballots to be counted.
But now we are up against the situation where
Donald Trump is going to try to stop the ballots
from being counted.
You have to really zoom out to understand
the authoritarian nature of what's going on.
Step one, claim of victory.
You didn't really win.
Trump may win, but when he claimed victory
last night, there was no one to claim claim
you were winning in states that you are not
actually winning in or where it is at least
unclear whether you are winning.
Trump did it.
And then when the numbers start to shift,
you have your own prior claims to point to.
Listen, I came out yesterday and we were ahead
and I said so.
And then now it's changing.
Well, what's inappropriate is not that they
are now counting ballots.
What was inappropriate was that he came out
and claimed victories.
He didn't actually have the mathematical standing
to claim.
So we need to be extraordinarily vigilant.
Now, I, I wish I could come to you and say
what it is that we should be doing.
I don't know.
I don't know if our systems are strong enough
to withstand this, because so far no system
has been able to hold Trump accountable.
Do we need to call our elected officials?
Who do we call?
What do we say?
What can they do?
If I call Ed Markey, say, you know, look at
what trumps what can Ed Markey do?
I don't know.
I don't actually know what to do.
It is a crisis situation.
So while we need to remain very calm as far
as.
We need to wait and see who wins a lot of
these states, Michigan looked very bad last
night, early for Joe Biden, then it looked
OK as of five minutes ago.
Biden's ahead in Michigan.
We have to wait.
We have to wait and see.
But the cat is out of the bag.
Trump is claiming they are stealing it from
him fraudulently.
Once that is done, it's crossing the Rubicon.
In a sense, there's no one ringing that bell.
If Donald Trump is starting with that this
early, that is what Donald Trump is going
to go with.
And we need to be very much prepared for it.
Let me know.
I want to hear from you.
What should I be advising the audience to
do to prevent Trump from making credible allegations
of fraud when there is no such evidence?
I wish I had something for you.
If you let me know, we can follow up on
it tomorrow.